you're not gonna believe this but racism
is alive and well in the United States
yeah that's right
after President Obama was re-elected the
second time around Jezebel did a story
or where they screen captured a
gajillion tweets people saying a lot of
racist stuff well then floating sheep
which is a group of geography academics
with the fun name they compiled this
stuff and they came up with some really
interesting information as to where here
you go we've got a map for you as to
where these racist tweets are coming
from now the more green you are the more
racist your tweets are and it's a that's
the density of tweets the red dots are
the the basic tweets but yeah southeast
United States a lot of racist tweets
coming out of there I guess that's not a
tremendous surprise terrible I'm racism
issed good I'm racism is because if I'm
not racist I'm racism it's because my
profile we're racists will be yeah and
I'm racism is cuz I got probably
Mississippi Alabama yeah that's bad of
me before you even saw the guy yeah
probably down there somewhere yeah let's
go back to the map so yeah it's really
it's focused down there the West look at
the West we're doing pretty well out
about West here we're not very racist on
the other hand what a utopia on earth
yeah they are not sending out I know
yeah ok so again this is information
based on after Obama was elected the
second half I thought guys and correct
me if I'm wrong I thought that we were
post-racial now and we had put this
thing to bed no there's just more ways
to post our racism so instead of the
Klansmen actually like burning the
steaks now they can just anonymously do
it on Twitter twitter is like the
profile photos of all these racist
people they're like it's like just in
the corner it's like some girl like
right or is there cash yeah yeah do me a
favor and don't make I mean I guess
that's the best to make it funny like
you expect it to be like all Klansmen
being like oh yes I do this is really
you're shocked that the Klan's people
don't put their own pictures on their
Twitter again I don't know we shot that
it's coming from a 14-year old girl on a
tank top with a Hello Kitty headband
yeah yeah yeah did you guys see that
this week that anonymous hacked into the
KKK is Twitter so they're now running
the KKK that's Twitter password was died
Blackie died that's all that I did it
right it probably wasn't that easy is it
social media you think like the best way
we can look at ourselves now is it the
best reflection of what really is going
on because if you're a racist now it's
not politically correct to be a racist
in society anymore so this stuff has
just shifted to the online world so is
that a better reflection of actually how
people feel then then what we say to
each other face-to-face or publicly here
well you might be right because I
thought it was exactly the opposite I
mean online I I was under the impression
that everybody wanted to pretend to be
somebody else the best version of
themselves the funniest the most
politically correct the whatever yeah
and this is showing the exact opposite
is when they're sending these racist
tweets are they trying to be the most
brazen the most edgy I don't know yeah
what do you think I I think it's a these
are just individuals who don't really
understand how like Twitter works favor
branding work I just think that some of
these might just not understand the say
things when no one else is watching so
maybe they haven't had that exposure to
like the general public's more developed
idea of racial equality and so they
unknowingly are like that say it around
here I'm just gonna say it to my friends
out here
unfortunately for them I guess
fortunately now they've now they find
out what everyone else thinks
yeah and they might think twice do you
guys think that Obama sort of can't win
when it comes to race like in a certain
way you I think you could make a pretty
strong case that he's been sort of
protected in a way by parts of the media
because he is black and at the same time
obviously there's a huge percentage of
people that don't like him because he's
black so is he just he can't win there
was no way to like sort of come out of
this eight years with it all feeling
right
I mean can't you kind of say that about
all of the other presidents - at this
point because you know there's plenty of
people that say well at least we still
got a white burning off and the other
and there's plenty of white people and a
plenty of people I think in general
they're like can we get a little
diversity you know everybody starts to
feel oppressed when we have one long
line of the same person running the free
world so I don't know that it is it any
different yeah I'm not sure I do I feel
like maybe at the end of this thing for
whatever reason America is gonna be like
we need a white guy again like Mitt
Romney is suddenly gonna look attractive
again because we need the most boring
white guy which is so sad
I don't even think it's gonna help can't
throw a baseball yeah have you ever seen
a bowl a bowling one yeah it's pretty
terrible yeah I I don't know I I think
maybe just to be optimistic and we've
got we we can just make a selection
based on what we need most of the nation
I I don't think it will enter in as much
next time I think you know the
discussion is like there's I forget what
magazine but the cover of I don't know
if it's time or one of those magazines
is like is Hillary inevitable is she
still inevitable so it's like the fact
that like a woman gets to be inevitable
you know right I I guess that maybe says
something good about us that it's not is
this woman inevitable it's like oh
here's a name of a person that they
decided might be the next president
right although when it comes to
inevitable so we have correct me if I'm
wrong on this we have Hillary 2016 then
we have Jeb 2024 then we have Chelsea
2032 then Malia 2040 then North West
then north west 2048 movie is gonna be
to turn North West may not be so I guess
it's a 2044 who do you got after that I
submit the Jaden I'm just saying like at
that point there will be no American
we can only hope